موافقه على هذا الاتفاق
لا تعني اتفاق مع طرف واحد او ما اجيها
محدده
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم مجلس السياده في السودان وقوه
مدنيه واقعه عن اتفاق اطار يدشن مرحله
انتقاليه يقودها مدنيون لمده عامين ويدمج
قوات الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه التي
فاقنا ترحيبا امنيا وافريقيا في حين رفضته
قوى مدنيه ووصفته بانه ادى الى انشقاقات
داخليه ولم يحضر بتوافق بقيه القوى
السياسيه
للشغل والجبهات الاخلاص للانتخابات
المقبله حركه النهضه تقول ان الانتخابات
لن تكون عنواننا للحل بل تكريسه لمزيد من
الانقسام وتؤكد وانا اداره الرئيس سعيد
تمضي في تكريس اوضاع اجتماعيه صعبه اسعار
النفط ترتفع بنحو ثلاثه في المئه مع بدي
سريان الحظر الاوروبيه على السراج الروسيه
بحرا ووضع سقف شعري بالاضافه الى تخفيف من
قيود كورونا مع عزيزه توقعات بشان انتعاش
الطلبه على الوقود في اكبر دوله مستورده
للنفط في العالم
ملعب وتسعه سبعه اربعه يا صديقي اخر
مباراه قبل تفكيكه تجمع البرازيل وكوريا
الجنوبيه ضمن مونديال قطر الملعب بني
جزئيا من حاويات الشحن ويعتبر اول ملعب
قابل للتفكيك في تاريخ كاس العالم وبحسب
المسؤولين القطريين سيتم تبرع بمكوناته
لاحد الدول الناميه الى اللقاء